ftth deployment in asia-pacific has just
reached a very important landmark and
I'm joined by the President of the
Council in that region bernard lee
burnett tell us first of all about this
incredible landmark 100 million lines a
hundred million lines is something that
we see as a huge milestone especially
this year it is a ten anniversary of the
council and we've seen as a new
beginning for council we are going to a
new phase in asia-pacific and we are
looking at beating dsl overtaking dsl by
2017 and i think this will give that
room that momentum to go to what's that
number where is most of this development
coming from at the moment within the
region well a lot of the major telcos
like for example the ones in China Japan
Korea Southeast Asia and also you all
the way down to oceanic countries like
New Zealand and so on they have pledged
this moving forward in FTTH and looking
at it you're looking at China being the
biggest number of ftth currently
followed by Japan and Korea and this is
just the tip of the iceberg although
China has the largest population of FTT
subscribers is only twenty percent
penetration so there is still a lot more
to go out absolutely yes now as well as
all the work you do across the countries
you now run a very prestigious
conference each year which is coming up
in jakarta tell us a bit about that well
interestingly jakarta was one of the
location that we selected mainly due to
a huge market potential a lot of you may
not know is that after china and india
indonesia has the largest population
asia-pacific people don't know that it's
amazing isn't it is yes and the new
government coming in saying that we need
to build intelligent country Indonesia
has to attract a lot of foreign direct
investment and one other infrastructure
they need to go is
and basically it is a huge market
potential for all fiber industry itself
and what about the council's work you
know what's next what's your next big
challenge yeah interesting right now
we've been asked many times so what else
you have done the fiber you're deployed
everywhere here heat 100 million what's
next the border actors last year came
out with new technology our new tech
line for the ftth council we're going to
promote FTTH to point o YC ftth to point
o is looking at how we monetize all the
different ways we can monetize the
existing infrastructure that has been
built by all the supporters FTTH and
move it to the next phase and this is
the ftth to point out we are looking at
okay well thanks for bringing us up to
data and good luck with the conference
thank you very so asia-pacific a region
fast growing and fast developing and
passing a major milestone